in this lecture we will move to the
opposite side of the world from the
Mediterranean
while in the west the new Roman Empire
was expanding in the East another great
Empire the Chinese Han was also
spreading
just like in the west the Han Empire
came into conflict with tribal people as
it expanded imposed new rules about
family life and stimulated rebellions
here in the East we will follow the
fortunes of Two Sisters in Vietnam who
rebelled against the powerful Han Empire
it's difficult to write about Trung
trock and her sister Trung Yi because
the sources of information are few and
the Contemporary texts were written by
the Chinese but I think the effort is
worth it because even today the Trung
sisters have become symbols of
Vietnamese identity and their struggle
for freedom
when I traveled in Vietnam and saw their
statues and festivals I wondered who
they were and what they did
here I can tell you what they did
who they were as women remains elusive
but what matters most is how they became
symbols of freedom for the people of
Vietnam
I'll begin their story in the year 25 in
the Red River delta in Vietnam where
truck and ye grew up
this region had been conquered by the
Han Dynasty of China more than a hundred
years earlier but life in the Delta was
about to change pulling the region into
Rebellion
first let's look at life in the Delta to
get an idea of traditional Vietnam
culture that was about to change
the tribes of this Delta had lived here
for centuries and they prospered because
of the richness of the river
the Red River rises in China and rushes
along for some 750 miles down through
Mountain Gorges before it spreads into
the delta this triangular region of some
five thousand square miles contains Rich
lowlands as the river system empties
into the Gulf of Tonkin near Hanoi the
region is full of mangrove swamps many
species of water birds and vicious
saltwater crocodiles villagers built
houses on stilts to keep out the water
and the animals and the design was so
effective that we can still see these
houses dotting the landscape in the
Foothills and river valleys
this region had been ruled by legendary
kings in the Hong Dynasty who had ruled
from about 2800 BCE these rulers
tattooed crocodiles on their thighs to
capture the courage of the fierce beasts
and to serve as tokens to keep the
animals away
recognizing these tattoos the Chinese
for centuries referred to Vietnam as the
land of the crocodile men
the Kings lived at the borders of the
lowland Delta and the neighboring Hills
so they could control both regions
were related to the legendary Hong Kings
on their maternal side this Noble
relationship gave them some License To
Rule and as we will see they would take
advantage of it
the villagers in the Delta prospered
because of the rich rice fields that
they irrigated from the rising Waters of
the Red River the Chinese had perfected
the domestication and cultivation of
rice in wet patties some ten thousand
years earlier and the spread of Rights
down to the Red River delta had been
lost in The Mists of time here in
Vietnam the cultivation had been firmly
established and the Delta produced two
abundant crops a year
people cultivated the rice helped by
their water buffaloes the people were
called the lock by the Chinese and the
name refers to the Vietnamese way of
irrigating their rights fields
the village is also grew rich on trade
that extended North to China and South
to the Mekong Delta and Beyond besides
their abundant rice the Vietnamese
traded their natural resources like
copper iron Gold Silver and Jade
they even grew Rich exporting calorie
shells much prized by the Chinese as
symbols of fertility and luck
the Locke tribes had learned to cast
bronze in about a thousand BCE and still
used bronze tools and weapons in the
year 25. today archaeologists call this
Bronze Age in Vietnam the dong-san
culture
their most striking artifact was a
bronze drum that they cast and decorated
beautifully some of the drums were of an
extraordinary size they could weigh up
to 159 pounds and required huge amounts
of smelted copper
but the drums sounded the heartbeat of
The Villages and Clans that spread
throughout the Delta and the neighboring
Highlands they were played for feasts
and funerals and they called the Clans
warriors together for War as we will see
soon the two Noble Trung sisters would
sound the drums for war
to begin to understand the origins of
the war we first must understand
something about the social life of the
Vietnamese and the status of their women
traditional Viet Society was based on
Clans not on nuclear families and Within
These Clans women carried a great deal
of sovereignty in fact some
anthropologists consider the dongsan
culture to be matriarchal with a child's
mother being much more important than
ties of paternity
young women were free to choose lovers
at spring festivals and if a girl became
pregnant during these events the young
man was to go to her clan marry her and
be accepted as a son-in-law if she did
not get pregnant she was free to choose
another young man
mothers were responsible for raising the
children and Proverbs Echo this ancient
time as they say a spoiled child is
attributable to the mother or
grandmother or if a child does wrong
it's the mother who Bears responsibility
this responsibility extended into
adulthood and women and grandmothers
were regularly consulted about the plans
and fortunes of their Clan
mother was a widow who raised her two
daughters on her own and this was
solidly within the matriarchal tradition
she taught the girls skills usual for
both women and men the girls learned to
raise silkworms and they also learned to
make roasted silkworm poop pie which is
a popular dish in North Vietnam today
but the girls were also brought up to
lead outside the home
their mother also had her daughters
trained in the martial arts sword
fighting and archery and they learned to
ride the war elephants that accompanied
the armies through the jungles
according to Legend Trung troch the
elder daughter was very heroic
courageous and good at bold stratagem
in 111 BC expanding Han dynasty of the
Chinese extended Southward and conquered
most of North Vietnam
the Chinese ruled the rich Red River
delta Province as well as the two
regions north and south of the Delta so
they controlled the whole Gulf of Tonkin
for over a century the Chinese rule
rested lightly on the land of the lock
the clan system remained in place and
women continued to wield a good deal of
authority the drums still sounded
through the hills and clans gathered
together to celebrate and sometimes
fight among each other
the Chinese influence was felt most
strongly in the prosperity That Grew as
trade from the Han Empire extended all
the way to the West connecting to the
Roman Empire across the famous Silk Road
the Chinese presence showed in garrisons
placed in the provinces
but they were only a token Force however
in 25 CE events far to the North in the
Han Empire created changes that would
affect the provinces far to the south in
Vietnam
what was going on in the North
a brief Revolution that overthrew the
Han Emperor for about 16 years caused a
backlash that rippled down into the
Delta changing the Status Quo
the Han Empire that had been established
in 206 BCE
experienced a brief lapse in rule when a
rebellion introduced a new Dynasty the
Jinn
this dynasty lasted only from 9 CE to 23
CE and was ruled only by one emperor the
newly restored Han Dynasty is called the
Eastern Han because its Emperors moved
the capital from shengang East
to luo Young the Eastern Han Empire
continued for another 200 years until
220 CE
the new Victorious Han Emperor took the
name Guang Woody when he took the throne
and he ruled until 57 CE a good long
Reign which gave him plenty of time to
implement changes that he was sure would
ensure the success of the Han Dynasty
and avoid future rebellions under Guang
Woody the light rule of the Han and
Vietnam changed
there were two related reforms that
Guang wudi introduced that changed
things throughout the Empire as well as
in Vietnam
first like many Emperors before and
since Wang Woody needed money to replace
the losses he incurred during the war
and to finance his new city so he raised
taxes all over the empire
to implement these new taxes in Vietnam
he sent a new governor to the South he
chose a man named Jen yen to serve as
prefect to Vietnam
we have a biography written to praise
Jen Yen so it emphasizes his
accomplishments but even if we make
allowances for his desire to praise his
deeds we can see that he made some
radical changes to life in Vietnam
his first claim was that he brought iron
and with the introduction of iron
Farming tools he increased production
we know that the Iron Age began in
Vietnam about this time so this is
probably accurate
gen Yen's second major reform was as
revolutionary
the Han Dynasty Emperors had begun to
embrace Confucianism as part of their
official policies
in a nutshell Confucius believed that a
good Society was a hierarchic society
with all content in their status and
obedient to those above them
everyone of course was obedient to the
emperor in this system women were also
placed in the hierarchy and they were
always to be subservient to fathers and
husbands and in their old age their sons
this philosophy was incompatible with
traditional Vietnamese views on women's
personal sovereignty and sexual freedom
Jen Yen wanted a society based on clear
family households with women subservient
to men and men subservient to rulers
cultural Clash was inevitable
the new Chinese Governor began to
enforce this view of the correct order
of society by focusing first on marriage
he passed a law ordering all men between
the ages of 20 and 50. to pick a partner
and marry all women between the ages of
15 and 40 were also to marry
he reputedly conducted a marriage
ceremony for a thousand couples
as Chinese concepts of marriage were
enforced through the Locke Society
traditional structures began to weaken
I want to stop this narrative for a
moment to consider how similar Jen Yen's
marriage laws are to Caesar augustus's
laws at the beginning of the Roman
Empire
in my lecture on Julia I showed how
sexual legislation caused even the
emperor's daughter to rebel and here at
the other side of the world the same
thing was happening it seems that these
Emperors found the control of marriage
to be Central to governing a
well-ordered state and as they impose
these rules women's roles became
restricted
Caesar Augustus was no confusion so the
Chinese motivation isn't likely to be
simply philosophical no gen Yin offered
a second motivation that was more
practical and perhaps more similar to
Roman motivations
it was easier to collect taxes from
identifiable households and nuclear
families Made Easy taxable targets so
Confucianism was a convenient philosophy
to impose
marriage was regulated and women's
Freedom was restricted
in any case marriage laws were
implemented in Vietnam taxes were raised
and people began to grow angry
about a decade after these laws were
imposed by the Han Dynasty a new
governor was appointed to the Delta
region this man was suiting and
according to even the Chinese sources he
was the worst kind of administrator he
was corrupt and laid ever heavier taxes
on the people his administration was so
bad that the Chinese sources wrote The
Hundred Clans clamor Injustice and stop
government officials on the roads to
complain
the bronze drums began to sound in the
Hills beating of their discontent with
this ruler and among the discontented
were a local ruler named tisak and his
wife Trung truk
they sought vociferously complained
about the treatment of the people and he
was killed for his outspoken objections
some sources say he was not killed but
just let his wife Take the Lead perhaps
the rumor of his death was a way to play
Down Trung truck's leadership but we'll
never know
in either case trungtrack decided it was
time to throw off the Chinese yoke she
enlisted her sister drew me and they
called together the local Clan leaders
and stirred them to fight
among the people truck recruited were
several women who had been entering into
small skirmishes with the Chinese even
the Trung sister's mother joined the
movement leading troops on her own
the combined forces included a number of
men and women generals fighting together
leading their own troops they began
their rebellion in the spring of 39 or
40 as people gathered together to
celebrate spring festivals the drums
called Fighters not only from the Delta
but from the neighboring provinces and
their growing Army included both men and
women
according to Legend which in this case
is plausible the sisters mounted war
elephants and led the armies
at first they had great success
elephants and horses served to move
troops through the forest trails and
bronze tipped arrows and Spears struck
with lethal Force these tribal armies
subdued local Chinese garrisons and the
Chinese sources write with disdain the
governor and the Chinese prefix could
barely manage to save their own skins
the women's armies managed to take 65
cities unifying the whole territory
under their rule
the end of the spring campaign saw these
stunning victories the people gathered
together and proclaimed Trung truck the
elder sister Queen
she began her benign rule in the year
40. establishing her Capital near modern
Hanoi in the rich Delta her first act as
Queen was to abolish the taxes that had
been imposed by the Chinese beyond that
Legend says that she ruled lightly
favoring trade both from the sea and
through the Woodland Trails into the
Highlands both these practices suggest
she wanted to restore the customs of the
Native Vietnamese as well as to Foster
the prosperity that had always come with
trade into the delta
it should come as no surprise that
Emperor Juan Woody would not leave the
Trung sisters in charge of these
prosperous provinces and what he
considered South China
in part the problem was their gender
a Neo Confucius saying claimed a woman
ruling is like a hen crowing
they were unnatural and unsuited to a
well-ordered kingdom no the empire was
going to strike back it just took some
time
it's about 860 miles from the Han
capital of La Yang to meilin which is
near Hanoi an ancient army would take
about three months to travel this
distance if conditions were good and
conditions were not good when traveling
to Vietnam
the first problem was the monsoon season
that brought daily deluges between May
and October there would be no traveling
through the Deep mud-swept paths during
that season in addition the Red River
delta surrounding Hanoi was itself
surrounded by a rough mountainous buffer
zone that was wild and inaccessible
independent tribes dotted the valleys
and it's still a region of many ethnic
minorities today that echoed the ancient
tribes who settled in the Hills
finally there is the problem of fighting
in the rainforests even Modern Warfare
in these conditions is difficult
the emperor Guang Woody took his time
preparing for war according to the
Chinese accounts he ordered troops to be
raised in his Southern provinces
then he repaired the roads and bridges
into Vietnam and ordered his men to cut
paths through the mountains in the high
mountain passes
he then commanded his people to prepare
carts to carry equipment and boats to
Ferry supplies along the coast
finally the emperor stockpiled rice to
supply what might be a long War
the Chinese could not use their Fierce
War chariots along the Forest Trails
this would be a slow march with horses
and foot soldiers through mountains and
forests but the emperor was patient
and relentless
with preparations made in the Summer of
42 the emperor appointed a general to
lead this Expedition he chose ma Yuan a
famous but elderly General who had
recently put down other rebellions
against the Han
the 58-year-old general was given the
designation the general who subdues the
waves
a nice euphemism for his charge of
ruthlessly subduing the lock Viet
Rebellion
mayuwan had some 20 000 troops at his
disposal
there were not enough boats to transport
the troops by sea so he began a long
Trek over land
took a year until 43 before ma Yuan
reached the delta
historians dispute where exactly the
general camped was it hotai the West
Lake in Hanoi perhaps but most suggest
he arrived in Chen do a wooded area in
the delta the chroniclers don't record
any military encounters between maiwan
and the Trung forces during his long
march to the Delta it may be that her
Scouts couldn't report his movements so
the women did not know exactly where he
was
it may also be that Trung truck waited
until he arrived to choose the time of
her confrontation
perhaps she trusted the difficult
Vietnamese terrain to take its toll if
so she was right
in his later Memoirs maywon recalled the
difficulties his forces faced his Fleet
Admiral had died of illness along the
way and things got worse in the camp as
the general wrote we had yet to defeat
the enemy yet the situation was such
that there was flooding everywhere with
thick clouds overhead and affluences
emanating in abundance one could look up
and see even vultures fall down to their
death as they flew by
okay I doubt that vultures were dropping
from the air but rain and malarial fever
would certainly have taken their toll
finally the Trung sisters decided to
engage One Source said only the younger
sister Trung Yi marched down with their
army to confront mayuwan the Chinese
were weakened and outnumbered
but the skill of the general more than
made up for these weaknesses
the discipline of the Chinese soldiers
confronted chaotic charges of tribal
forces and the Vietnamese were soundly
defeated
several thousand of the Trung's troops
were killed and over ten thousand either
surrendered or were captured the sisters
fled the field
the trunks fled to the kamke district to
the west and gathered some of their
remaining forces to them
there are several different versions
about what happened next but beyond the
differing details of location and
engagements the general outlines of the
story are clear
it took my Yuan some years to follow the
rebellious forces during that time Trung
truck and Trung Yi engage the Chinese
forces repeatedly
they lost every encounter and had to
retreat into the hills and the forests
in the end my Yuan managed to kill both
sisters he chopped off their heads and
had them sent back to Luol young to the
emperor to prove his victory
the Vietnamese Legends offer a slightly
different ending to the story they write
when they reached the dead end in kamke
the Two Sisters in despair had to drown
themselves in the hot River
this is a more heroic end the sisters
weren't killed they chose to sacrifice
themselves for the cause of Vietnamese
Independence
this becomes the prevailing Legend but I
am inclined to believe the Chinese story
my Yuan had pursued them too long to let
them die in peace
the death of the Trung sisters did not
end the Rebellion mayuwan took two
thousand votes and twenty thousand more
soldiers to pursue the remnants of trong
truck's Army he killed decapitated and
arrested over five thousand soldiers it
took him a couple more years for this
mop-up operation
he had to cut tunnels through mountains
to move his troops and had to take land
routes to avoid choppy Seas along the
coast but in the end he prevailed
maiwan's goal was not only to win a
military Victory he wanted to convert
the region to a fully Chinese province
to achieve this goal he confiscated the
great bronze drums that had echoed
through the region this act both
attacked the identity of the clans of
the region and cut off their means of
summoning each other to battle
he had these drums melted down to make a
solid bronze horse to present to the
Emperor as a victory token
once majuan had pacified the region the
Chinese garrisons were once more
installed
taxes continued to be collected and sent
North to China
the noble children of Vietnam began to
go to Chinese schools where they studied
Confucian texts slowly old ideas of
matriarchy and tribal Society began to
give way to hierarchy and patriarchy
this was my Juan's real victory
this could have been the story of the
rebellion of the Trung sisters who ruled
for only a couple of years
but history sometimes takes peculiar
turns
often what matters most is how people
are remembered and in time the troom
sisters became among the most important
women in Vietnamese history
they became symbols of freedom as one
modern historian has written the trungs
crystallized the idea of freedom and
Independence in the mind of the Locke
people and their descendants as well as
the idea that they belonged to a
different cultural group than the
Chinese
sometime after their deaths people
erected altars to the Trung's sacrifice
the most famous is in Hanoi today
this Temple was founded in 1087 and
rebuilt in 1142 at the site where it
stands today
the sanctuary contains statues of the
Two Sisters kneeling with arms raised as
if to inspire a crowd once a year the
statues are carried to the Red River
taken out in a boat and carefully washed
before they are brought back to the
temple
over time people gave offerings at these
altars and sometimes Small Miracles seem
to have appeared rain saves a crop a
child is healed at a national level
whenever the Vietnamese struggled to
overthrow Invaders the Trung sisters
were invoked as symbols and models to
follow
and 248 another woman invoked the Trung
sisters as she led a revolt against the
Chinese lady Trio as she was popularly
known fought for years before she
drowned herself in a river to avoid
being defeated
the uprising ended but again people
remembered the struggle led by a woman
finally the Chinese rule ended in 939
and the newly installed Vietnamese
rulers offered sacrifices at the shrines
of the Trung sisters
but their story doesn't end even here
the history of Vietnam is filled with
ongoing Wars against Invaders from
future Chinese invasions to the French
Colonial period to the devastating
American war the Trung sisters were
invoked as the patients of the
Vietnamese people to struggle for
Independence
the sisters did not just remain symbolic
however they inspired real people real
women to participate in the wars in the
peninsula and the American war women
fought with North Vietnamese Viet Cong
forces at all levels
today now that peace has finally come to
Vietnam people still celebrate the
sacrifice of the Trung sisters their
statues of the sisters in Hanoi and in
Ho Chi Minh City former Saigon in fact I
became curious about these women
warriors when I traveled in Vietnam and
saw their statues that are so respected
countries choose their symbols hold on
to them tenaciously and such symbols
create a national identity that's the
influence of Trung troch and Trung ye
the celebration of their lives continues
today there is an annual holiday in
February to commemorate the deaths of
the Trung sisters and two lucky women
are chosen to embody the sisters and
ride great decorated elephants in a
parade
[Music]
have assumed a position in Vietnamese
culture that is for me astonishingly
disproportionate to their brief lives
they became symbols of a Vietnamese
identity that remained even as the
people spoke Chinese and adopted
Confucian ideology
one modern Vietnamese historian wrote
that after each political victory people
turned to the trunks to say
you led the way Queens
we just followed you
there's no more powerful tribute than
that